at the beginning of the movie we are
introduced to our protagonist in Su a
young college student with a unique
ability he can see ghosts roaming around
him he constantly wears a mysterious
locket that starts to spin whenever a
spirit approaches unfortunately because
of this Supernatural ability he is often
bullied by his classmates who call him
the ghost Seer they could do better than
that what about douche Willis one day
while on the subway in Sue's locket goes
crazy telling him there's a ghost nearby
when he looks around he sees a young
girl's ghost among the busy Subway crowd
this unsettles ensu prompting him to
quickly get out of the Metro he then
rushes back home and scans the room with
his locket at first insue finds nothing
and gets relieved but then the locket
starts spinning and he spots the ghost
sitting on his shoulders here it is
revealed that the ghosts do not approach
ensu to harm him in fact they just want
help from him and this particular ghost
appears to have been murdered so she
forms him about her Corpse's location
she only wants her parents to find
Solace at first ensu hesitates but after
a lot of convincing he contacts the cops
and settles the case although he helps
the ghost with her request iansu is
tired of his abilities he simply wants
to lead a normal life and make friends
therefore he decides to quit school and
seek answers in his hometown he contacts
his uncle hakaru and lets him know that
he is coming the latter tries to
dissuade him saying that his studies are
important but he ensue does not listen
Dad if one more ghost sits on my face
I'm gonna freak in the next scene he
returns to his hometown and along the
way he spots a beautiful girl named Rose
later ensu meets his uncle he seems to
have the same capacity to see ghosts
like him not only this he is a master
Exorcist who is known for banishing
ghosts to the afterlife the next day in
Sue gets admitted to his childhood
School the teacher introduces him to
everyone and Ian Sue hopes that he can
have a fresh start here unfortunately a
group of bullies notice him and
immediately start tormenting him one of
the bullies named hyunji even flirts
with him despite having a boyfriend Hai
Chul she thinks he's the Bruce chillest
as all of this is going on in Sue spots
a female ghost wearing a mask outside
the classroom and becomes horrified
later as he is returning home from
school haichul suddenly attacks him from
behind and beats him up the bully warns
Ian Sue to stay away from his girlfriend
even though she was the one flirting
haichul then threatens our boy by
bringing up the case of a certain ah
young she died under mysterious
circumstances years back and Dean Sue
was visited by her ghost numerous times
she always pleaded for help but ensu
never had the courage to do so this was
one of the main reasons why he
transferred to the city the scene then
cuts to one of the female boys who
returns home and discovers a polythene
bag hanging on the front door when she
tries opening it the polythene breaks
and blood spills all over her face
scared the bully desperately tries to
phone her friends but the call just
won't connect then in the blink of an
eye
masked ghost from earlier attacks her
and finishes her off that was the point
of the blood bag later we see in Sue
sitting with the same girl from earlier
Rose she is actually a ghost who died
some years back but since she isn't
scary and ugly like the others insue
likes talking to her suddenly wind
starts to blow and Rose tells ensu that
the masked girl is near them this
frightens our boy and he immediately
runs away from there the next day at
school as hyunji is harassing a boy in
front of the entire class ensue gets fed
up and intervenes he orders her to stop
the bullying once and for all as
expected the other bullies spring
forward to beat insue up but hyunji
stops them it appears that she has
started liking him she might even like a
look at his Bruce Willis in the evening
as insu and his uncle are watching the
news they see a solved murder case where
the Killer is finally apprehended after
10 years he is found to be wearing a
mask this immediately catches in Sue's
attention as he recalls the masked ghost
he saw at school he talks about her with
his uncle hoping to find any information
just then a female Spirit who appears to
be living in the same house reveals that
the masked girl's name is Sai hee
meanwhile a couple from the bully gang
sneaks into the school at night they are
there to get back the girl's cell phone
which was seized by one of the teachers
earlier after getting the job done they
enter a classroom and have some fun then
the girl rushes to the washroom leaving
the boy alone while waiting for her to
return suddenly the masked ghost Sai he
appears and kills him after this she
confronts the other bully in the
bathroom stall and finishes her off as
well the following day the entire school
is shaken up by the murders in
particular hyunji appears to be
distressed as all her friends are being
targeted one after another meanwhile
insu tries to gather information on the
masked ghost sahi He inquires with
everyone in the classroom but no one
dares to talk about sahi despite the
fact that they are aware of her it
appears that her death had something to
do with the bully group later while ensu
and Rose are enjoying their time
together he receives a message from one
of his classmates she includes a photo
of sahi as well as a statement
mentioning that she should not be
questioned about saihi anymore Ian Sue
then asks Rose if she knows anything
about saihi in response the beautiful
ghost girl says that the entire School
knows how she
hearing this it finally Dawns on Ian
seal that the bully group was
responsible for saihi's death filled
with rage he attacks haichu from behind
but the bully easily overpowers him and
beats him up instead nonetheless ensu
with a wicked smile on his face says Sai
he is coming for you all later when the
bullies are returning home hyunji shows
haichul a picture of saehi's father and
links it with her friend's murders she
is certain that the old man is killing
all the bullies one by one as an act of
Vengeance haichul agrees with her
assumption and together they decide to
head towards sahi's house and kill her
father before heading there though
hyunji secretly messages about their
plan in the next scene insu receives the
message and informs his uncle about the
situation even though he despises the
bullies he knows that their lives are in
danger hence he decides to stop them
before it's too late Hikaru asks him to
be careful and gives him a magical
dagger for protection on on the other
hand is haichul and hyunji enter the
house they are startled by a continuous
thumping sound coming from a box at the
same time they noticed some flashy
images of the dead girl Sai he at this
point they realized that insu is
speaking the truth Sai he has indeed
come out for Revenge terrified the
bullies try to run away but at the same
time saihi's father mysteriously pops
out of the box and finishes off high
Chul seeing her boyfriend die in such a
brutal fashion at hyunji begs for her
life she even apologizes for everything
that she did in the past however the
father doesn't listen to her words and
kills her as well in the aftermath insu
finally arrives at the scene he enters
the house to find his classmates lying
limp on the floor he also notices say
he's father and realizes that he has
been possessed by his daughter's ghost
just as Ian Sue is about to leave he
hears a sound coming from a nearby
closet inside he finds sahi with her
usual mask on ensue courageously unmasks
her and discovers that she is none other
than Rose following this we are taken to
the past to find out what really
happened say he was a fun-loving girl at
the same school but just like the others
she was also tormented by the bully
group one day after reaching her
Breaking Point she complained to the
Head teacher about hyunji's bullying
behavior taking the matter seriously the
teacher insulted hyunji in front of
everyone this enraged the bully girl so
much that she decided to make saihi's
life a living hell from the next day
onwards hyunji and her gang started
treating sahi like an animal they beat
her up pulled her hair set fire to her
hair and even forced her to wear a mask
all the students in the class witnessed
this but they never spoke up due to fear
of meeting the same fate the constant
torture took a toll on saihi's life and
she cried all the time at home her
concerned father advised her to contact
the head teacher but sahi declined
saying this would only escalate things
then one day fed up with the constant
use she committed the unthinkable in the
afterlife her spirit split into two
personalities the first one is Rose who
resembles the actual Psy he sweet and
always helpful to others the second one
is the masked girl who is on a quest to
eliminate all her tormentors in the
present insu discovers a diary in which
all of the victims names have been
crossed out except for the head teacher
this means that the masked girl is not
done with her killings yet scared iinsu
immediately calls his uncle and requests
him to go to sahi's house and execute
the burial rights he then proceeds to
the school in order to save the head
teacher in the next scene as the head
teacher is working alone she is
confronted by PSY Spirit shortly after
Ian Sue arrives at the school and he
immediately inquires about the teacher
however no one seems to have seen her
suddenly the lights go out and PSY he
appears in front of them having
possessed the head Teacher's Body she
then reveals her true masked self and
says that since they all turned to Blind
died at her when she was being bullied
they all deserve to be punished ensue
attempts to stop her but Psy grabs a
lighter and throws it on the ground or
gasoline was thrown before at this
moment it appears that all the students
are going to be burned to death but
surprisingly Rose the alter ego of Psy
he catches the lighter before it can hit
the ground the two then have a ghastly
conversation where Rose tries to stop
her other self from harming the students
however Psy he who is much more powerful
easily swats away Rose making her
disappear this split personality demon
can handle physical things and it banish
itself gonna have to Nerf that in
the next patch on the other hand hakaru
reaches saihi's house and starts his
Supernatural procedure with her
spiritual strength Psy he begins to
shatter everything in her path on the
other side iinsu begins checking the
magical locket on anyone who could be
possessed by Rose when he discovers the
lockets spinning around a girl he tells
her to stop everything and provides her
with a notebook that he found inside's
container the scene swings back to a
flashback revealing that Ian seal and
Sai hee were childhood friends they
appeared to be in love and Dean Sue had
sketched a picture of her in his
notebook in the present he apologizes to
Rose's spirit for failing to identify
her the distraction proves to be enough
as Hikaru completes his task on the
other end as the poor girl's spirit is
finally liberated the dagger in ensu's
Pocket starts to Glow or is he just
happy to see her Rose pulls it out and
immediately stabs herself oh damn after
which we see a flashback of insu and
saees wonderful memories in the final
scene all of the students are shown
mourning at saihi's grave in Sue is also
present with a beautiful sketch of his
beloved Rose subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching